the price of oil matters because it
impacts the cost of everything from
consumer goods to manufacturing and to
fuel making it a key driver of inflation
that's why this group of 13 Nations
known as OPEC short for the organization
of petroleum exporting countries is so
influential they're often joined by 10
other oil producing Nations including
Russia this group is referred to as OPEC
plus and produces about 40 percent of
the world's crude oil their supply
relative to Global demand has a huge
impact on price so let's take a look at
this graph showing the price per barrel
of Brent crude oil over the last three
years just to see a few examples so this
is when kovid hit back in early 2020 the
world shut down meaning a huge slump in
demand and a collapse in price by
contrast this is when Russia invaded
Ukraine early last year and there was
concern about an oil shortage sending
the price well above a hundred and
twenty dollars per barrel since then
there's generally speaking and been
weaker demand from China and fears of a
global economic contraction but on
Sunday there was a bit of a surprise
Saudi Arabia Iraq and several Gulf
States or unexpectedly announced they
would cut Supply by more than a million
barrels a day and the result Brent crude
up by more than five percent but for
some this isn't just about price it's
about power and Saudi Arabia defying
America's request to keep Supply steady
if a decision is taken by one of the
largest producers in their let's say
Saudis and and the other countries from
the cartel are taken on board then this
is basically the major bulk of the
market is able to move in concert and
there is very little in terms of
political or Market leverage
um the other oil producers can do and
there is also very little that all
consumers can do aside from actually
doubling down and reducing overall
demand
but that might be challenging even with
the global push to decarbonize there are
predictions that world oil demand is
likely to accelerate sharply this year
as air travel rebounds and China opens
up again after covet